[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 106 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm
here with my colleague Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm doing good.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
You're not here
in San Francisco.
Where are you?
MELANIE WARRICK:
I'm in Los Angeles.
I'm attending NIPS this week,
which is the Neural Information
Processing Summit.
MARK MANDEL: Very
nice, very nice.
Getting some nice
sunny weather, I hope.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
definitely warm and sunny
this wonderful holiday season.
MARK MANDEL: [LAUGHING] Great.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's very on theme.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
I'm very used to a warm
December, being from Australia.
MELANIE WARRICK: I was going
to say, it's probably familiar.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
MELANIE WARRICK: How is it
for you, doing Christmas
without the warmth now?
Like, what is that like?
MARK MANDEL: December's
barbecue season.
I don't understand why it
would be any different.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
you can still barbecue.
It's not like you really can't.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
It's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
anyway, we should
go ahead and get to the meat
of what we are really here
to talk about, which is the
"New York Times" interview that
was with Deep Kapadia
and JP Robinson.
And They come to us to talk
about how "New York Times" is
using TCP, and Deep Kapadia
is the executive director
of engineering,
while JP Robinson
is the principal
software engineer.
Of course, after
this interview, we're
going to touch on a question
of the week, which is about--
Mark, you want to set that up?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so we're going
to have a chat about best
practices for securing
your Kubernetes engine cluster
and the containers that
run upon them.
MELANIE WARRICK: And of course,
before we do all of that,
we'll get to what are the
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome,
so cool things
of the week-- we have a lot of
Kubernetes stuff and container
stuff.
I will start with my favorite
one because cheaper is good.
We are cutting the
cluster management fees
on Google's Kubernetes engine.
So if you've ever used
GKE on us before, you
may know that, previously,
six plus nodes--
if you had more than six
nodes running on GKE,
it was $0.15 an hour.
Now, effective
immediately-- actually,
effective as before
this podcast came out--
$0.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's a good
thing-- constant reduction.
Lots of reduction.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
really-- that's it.
Very simple.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And another thing
for the week that
we wanted to mention
is that GCP is going to be
available in Hong Kong in 2018.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so if
you live in that region,
2018's going to be a good year.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Another
region for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Reducing
latency all the time.
Last thing?
MARK MANDEL: Last thing?
There's a really cool article
about introducing an easy way
to deploy containers on
Google Compute Engine.
I like this one because,
sometimes, you're like,
oh, I have a container.
Maybe you found something
on Docker Hub that you like.
Maybe you want to run Redis
or some sort of Wordpress
instance, or who knows what.
But it's-- on Docker Hub is
an image, but you're like,
Kubernetes-- that seems
like a lot of work.
I just want to run this on a
single VM sitting somewhere,
or maybe even in a group.
But I just want
something simple.
Now, you can basically go
over to GCE Compute Engine
and say, hey, I'd like
to create an instance,
and here's the container
I want you to run on it.
Boom, done.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
And you can tie that into
managed instance groups,
too, and auto scaling
if you need to,
but I really think
it's kind of nice just
to have this really simple
thing where you're like,
oh, I just need to run an
instance of Redis or something
like that, and then it's
just very simple to set up
with something out
of hub.docker.com.
MELANIE WARRICK:
All right, so let's
go ahead and get started
with the interview.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Let's go talk to our
friends at "New York Times."
Today, I am extra excited--
I'm always excited-- to have two
wonderful people here joining
us today, Deep Kapadia and
JB Robinson-- or JP Robinson,
I should say--
both from the New York Times.
Thank you so much for
joining us today here
to talk about
basically everything
you do with GCP
and New York Times.
JP, how are you doing?
JP ROBINSON: Wonderful, thanks.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
Deep, how are you doing today?
DEEP KAPADIA: Excellent.
Thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Yeah, thanks again for agreeing
to join us on the podcast today
to talk about everything you do
with GCP at the New York Times.
Before we get stuck
into that, and I'm
super excited to do
that, why don't you
tell us a little about who
you are and what you do.
Deep, why don't you go first?
DEEP KAPADIA: Yeah, so I'm
the director of engineering.
I run our infrastructure
and operations teams,
and also our test
automation team,
which is something I picked up
along the way at some point.
And my teams are mostly
responsible for pretty much
managing all of our
cloud infrastructure
tooling, which includes
the Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
What about you, JP?
JP ROBINSON: I am a
principal software engineer.
Really, I own and maintain all
of our internal and open source
libraries and packages, when
it comes to the Go Programming
language.
And I also lead back-end
development for our games
team--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
JP ROBINSON: --so for the
crossword and all the fun Toys
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we used that
as a cool thing of the week
not that long ago,
when you announced--
you wrote a blockbuster on how
you moved the crossword to App
Engine and Go.
That was a really
good blog post,
not only because it was
about Go, but also because it
was about games.
JP ROBINSON: Yeah, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, so-- OK, so
let's talk high-level first.
I'm guessing probably Deep is
the best question for this.
So New York Times, isn't
this a paper publication?
Like, what do you actually
do on the internet?
DEEP KAPADIA: Oh, that's
an interesting one.
So yes, we started out as a
paper publication in 1851.
But since then, we've
embraced other ways
of telling stories, one of them
being telling stories online.
We, in fact, launched our first
website, believe it or not,
in 1996, before most
people had a website.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
We've We've had an online
presence for a long time.
And along the way, we've
sort of transformed
the way we tell stories.
Like, we're doing a
lot of publications
just for consumption online.
So we have a huge
video production team.
We also have a daily
podcast called The Daily.
We also have a
virtual reality app.
If you have an
Android or iOS phone,
you can download it
from the app stores.
So there's a lot of things
we've sort of experimented
with along the way.
But most importantly, we
have our website, which
is fairly well trafficked.
We get about--
I think, our homepage
used to get about, like,
50 million hits a day.
I don't know what the latest
number is at this point.
And then, JP has all his games
apps that he can tell you guys
about.
JP ROBINSON: Sure.
So yeah, beyond, you
know, just servicing up
the news and all of our news
products associated with
that, we have had historically,
along with the website,
our crossword as a
digital offering.
And a big push from that,
when it comes to technology,
is that not only are we
serving up the crossword,
but we allow you to play
the crossword on one device,
and then we try to seamlessly
sync it to all of your devices
that may be logged in.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
JP ROBINSON: So yeah,
it's a lot of stuff.
And on top of
that, you know, all
of these products
and services also
have a layer of
personalization built in.
So there's obviously
a lot of technology
backing all of that fun stuff.
DEEP KAPADIA: And
we're constantly
trying to come up with new
ways of, like, repurposing
our content, right?
So we've always had recipes
in our management system.
But at one point, we
decided, like, you
know, how about we build
a cooking app where people
can have annotations
on their recipes,
and actually share their
recipes with each other, etc.
So somewhere along the line,
we created a new products
division, which was building
all these experiments and sort
of trying to see if we
could prioritize them.
As it stands now,
our cooking app
has its own stream of revenue.
It's available on the
app store, and, like,
you know, people-- you can
just buy a subscription to it.
So there's definitely
lots of different things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So while you were describing
all of the cool things you do,
I actually went through
the Internet Archive,
and I found a screenshot of your
web page on November 12, 1996.
And I've got to say--
yeah, I've got to say, I'm
very happy that we've evolved,
because that's a very,
very cool web page.
I'll put a link
in the show notes.
It's actually worth seeing
it back then, and now again.
MARK MANDEL:
Genuinely fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is, yeah.
JP ROBINSON: It truly
was just a single GIF.
That's all we put up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it was a GIF.
That's it.
It is pretty cool.
Anyway, since-- you've
talked a little bit
about all of the cool things
you do on the New York Times.
But our audience is,
you know, like-- we
are into technical details.
Tell us a little bit about
how you do this, like,
we know you're using a pension
for some of the things.
Do you use a pension
for everything?
How does this work?
DEEP KAPADIA: No,
actually, we don't
use App Engine for everything.
So I mean, we're in a bit
of a transition right now.
So, you know, as I
said, like, you know,
we've had a website
since a while now.
So at some point,
like, our operations
became large enough for us
to sort of consider, like,
having our own data centers.
So we were running in our
co-located data centers--
like, we have one on the east
coast, one on the west coast,
and a few peripheral
ones here and there.
We have one in our
building in Manhattan,
which is quite expensive real
estate for a data center.
So we've largely been running
applications in our own data
center, like, you know, with
a layer of virtualization
on top of the bare metal
that we were running.
About six years ago, I think,
we decided to start looking at,
like, this Cloud thing that
people were talking about.
So we started, like, building
some apps in the Amazon Cloud.
But you know, one of the
things we tried to do
was pretty much replicate
what we were doing in our data
centers in the Cloud, which
was probably not the most
ideal way to go about it.
So what we were trying
to do-- at some point,
we sort of decided we
needed better abstractions
to build our applications.
Granted, like, you know, we
were largely a news and media
organization.
So I mean, technology
isn't quite our forte.
Even though we're
pretty good at it,
we feel that, like,
you know, we want
to be building more applications
and less infrastructure.
So that prompted us to
go and, like, you know,
evaluate what we're doing.
And at some point, we
decided that we want
to move entirely to the Cloud.
So that's where Google comes in.
And you know, for some
of the applications,
it seemed like App Engine
was a really good fit,
especially, you know, JP started
looking at the App Engine
sometime last year.
And he found it a very good fit
for some of the applications he
was building.
But on the whole,
like, when we look
at some of the applications we
have, you know, a lot of those
could be containerized
fairly easily.
So Google also provided us
with a very good abstraction
to deploy containers,
which was Google Kontainer
Engine, or GKE.
And, you know, it gives
us all the benefits
of running in Kubernetes
without actually having
to run Kubernetes ourselves.
So both the App Engine
and GKE together
were a bit of a
game changer for us
on the application
development side.
And I said, like, you know,
we were running our own data
centers.
We also had this
large loop cluster
that we were doing all
sorts of data processing
and like, you know,
data analysis.
At some point,
like, our data team
decided to try out BigQuery.
Like, they were
completely blown away
with all the features it had
and, like, you know how--
with the ease of use.
So BigQuery was sort of
like the gateway drug for us
to start looking at other
Google abstractions.
And then that led to us using
App Engine and Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
We've heard that many times.
People try BigQuery, and after
that, they're like, oh, oh wow.
Yeah, that's cool.
MARK MANDEL: That is cool.
So I'm actually kind of
curious to kind of probably
dig a little deeper.
App Engine, Kubernetes,
this is a common thing
that I hear from
a lot of people.
How do you end up choosing which
piece goes on which platform?
DEEP KAPADIA: At
this point, we don't.
So in the sense
that, you know, like,
we sort of give
people the option
and say, like, figure out
what works for you the best.
Like, what my team did
was we provided our users
with a consistent way to
deploy on both engine, as well
as Kubernetes.
We use a CI tool called Drone.
And we host Drone internally.
And we built a
couple of plug-ins
that allow us to deploy the
code on GKE or App Engine.
And both those plug-ins seem
to work, for the most part.
Like, of course, like, you
know, there's definitely--
people are always asking
for more and more features,
and that kind of
stuff, and like,
for the pipeline to be
more and more fancy.
People want to do all sorts of
blue-green deploys and things
like that.
But for the most
part, it seems to work
if you want to get your
code from your laptop
to App Engine or GKE.
And then they decide
what works best for them.
Typically, if it's
a go application,
I often see JP
sort of swooping in
and, like, giving them the spiel
about all the benefits of going
on App Engine Standard,
et cetera, et cetera.
And he can tell you
more about that.
But that's typically how things
have been working so far.
MARK MANDEL: JP, did
you want to weigh in?
JP ROBINSON: Sure.
So yeah, I mean, it really
comes down to, you know,
what's the basic thing
you're Building, oftentimes.
For us, it's just a simple
API or something like that,
I need to store some data and
retrieve it later-- that kind
of stuff.
And a lot of times, it really
just comes down to App Engine
and Data Store is really enough.
I find that we really--
we still make GKE
an option, in case
you need to do something
crazy or something
that's not necessarily
API-service-oriented.
Like, even for my
work, sometimes, like,
I have a process that just
needs to generate PDFs.
I can't really do
that in App Engine.
So I just have something
listening to a Pub/Sub,
generating PDFs, and spitting
them back on Pub/Sub.
So it's really, like--
if it's something basic,
something simple that you
can build in, like, a
day, a lot of times,
I will just point
people to App Engine
and they don't have to
worry about anything
beyond the product.
And Kubernetes if you
want to get crazy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'm curious about the
developer experience.
You told us a little bit
about the Drone plug-ins
that you used at--
by the way, we also
used as a thing of the
week, a long time ago.
MARK MANDEL: They do
seem to show up a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
because they're open-source,
and we love open-source.
Could you tell us a
bit more about how
does it look like when
you're actually testing?
Do you have a QA environment
different to the App Engine--
like, do you have different
App Engine projects?
How do you manage all of this?
JP ROBINSON: So from an
App Engine perspective,
we generally have a
project per environment.
I've got one for,
like, our staging,
and one for production, and one
for, like, our sandbox or lab,
or whatever you want to call it.
And we do, like, just
a normal get flow.
You know, you'll check
in a feature branch.
Once that gets blessed onto
our development branch,
it will get pushed out
to one environment.
Once it's merged
into Master, it will
go to the staging environment.
And then, we will tag
the repo with a release.
And that will kick off
a production deployment.
So it's pretty straightforward.
And it's very similar
for GKE or App Engine,
really just kind of get oriented
and kind of event driven.
DEEP KAPADIA: What JP said.
MARK MANDEL: As we
mentioned before,
you open-source the
plug-ins for Drone.
So I'm curious, as an
organization, is, like,
open-source something
that's important to you?
Or has it just been,
like, you thought
these might be useful
for other people?
What was the story with that?
DEEP KAPADIA: Both.
We definitely want to be a part
of the open-source community.
But at the same
time, we also want
to be using tools that
can be supported widely.
So that was one of the
very big reasons for us
to sort of look at Drone
in the first place.
And then on top of
that, like, I think,
once we found out that this
could be completely useful--
and there's nothing proprietary
about a fairly simple plug-in
that, like, you know, just
deploys code to a set of GKE
instances--
it was pretty much a non-brainer
for us to say, like, you know,
let's just open-source it.
But on the whole, we do find
ourselves embracing a lot
of open standards and
open-source technologies .
Like, one of the big reasons
for us to sort of buy into GKE
was Kubernetes itself
being an open standard.
As I said, like,
you know, we did
dabble in AWS for a long time.
And a lot of our workloads
still run in AWS.
I know this is a GCP podcast.
But the thing is, like,
something like Kubernetes
would maybe, at some point,
allow us to run workloads
in AWS, as well as GCP.
So it's a fairly open standard.
It's portable.
As long as we're deploying
to containers, you know,
we should be able to move our
workloads just about anywhere.
So that was one of the things.
And the other thing is we use
a lot of tools from HashiCorp.
They're all written in Go.
So you know, at least on
the deployment automation
side of things, you're
trying to use a lot of Go.
And a lot of the Go community is
already embracing open-source.
It's online.
And you know, we're often
contributing to some
of the HashiCorp products.
So we do contribute
to Terraform.
We've contributed to
a couple other things.
We've also contributed to
Kubernetes a little bit.
So it allows us to
also sort of shape
the direction of some of
these things, as well.
JP ROBINSON: I think
from my perspective,
too, I think not only
when we're open-sourcing
these tools in
libraries and things
like that, not only is it
for us to help other people
and, like, to be part of
the open-source community,
but from my
perspective, it often
helps us make that tool
or that library better.
I've even had, like,
several-- like,
Marvin, our App Engine
framework for Go,
like, immediately
after we published it,
even had some nice contributors
from Google themselves
that helped us clean it
up and make it better.
I just love random people on
the Internet fixing my things,
really.
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
You mentioned something
there, Deep, really
sort of sidehandedly.
Like, you said you're still
running a little bit on AWS.
Are you still also
running on Prem?
Like, are you running your
own data center still?
Did you end up finishing
that migration?
What happened there?
DEEP KAPADIA: So no, we haven't
finished the migration yet.
We are slated to finish it in
the second quarter of 2018.
We are still in the middle of
this huge, huge migration from,
like--
our data centers is
completely glued to the Cloud.
JP ROBINSON: Yeah,
we just finally--
I think, games, we
are the first people,
I think, to get complete
public traffic off
of AWS in the past
couple of weeks now,
which has been really nice.
DEEP KAPADIA: To give
you more context, though,
like, our website is going
to be hosted on GKE, as well.
So if you go to nytimes.com
on your mobile phone,
you are hitting a GKE
cluster that point.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, so you've
mentioned that you have systems
running on Google
Cloud platform,
you have systems
running on Amazon,
and you also have systems
running on Premise.
Now, the question
is, how do you even
monitor all of these
things together?
DEEP KAPADIA: So
that's a hard one,
because a lot of these systems
are at very different states
of maturity.
So like, we do have an
infrastructure and a systems
team that was already
managing our data center, that
was actually building
things for our data center,
and managing things
in our data center.
So they continue to
exist at this point,
and will continue to exist
for the foreseeable future,
because, you know,
there is a lot of craft
already out there
in our data centers.
And a lot of these systems
are going to be forklifted.
So, you know, things
that were running on VMs
will probably continue to run
on VMs unless we re-platform
them to either run on something
like App Engine or Containers.
So that's not going away.
We have the traditional way
of maintaining and managing
the systems in our data centers.
For AWS, there is a little
bit more automation.
We were using, or
we still are using,
Puppet and some
configuration management
tools to manage some of
the systems in Amazon.
However, on the Google Cloud,
we've sort of gone all in
and said, like, you know,
we're going to do Kubernetes,
and we're going
to do Containers,
and, like, you know,
use Drone, and, like,
have this faster CI
pipeline that allows
us to deploy stuff to Google.
Over time, though, we hope
that, like, once we're fully
in the Cloud, both
Google and Amazon,
we can use certain
abstractions that
allow us to sort of deploy code,
either in Google or Amazon,
the same way.
So one of the ways
that we are trying
to rationalize some of the
infrastructure automation
is by using tools
like Terraform,
which has support for both
Google as well as Amazon.
You know, again, one of
the choices with Kubernetes
is, as I said, was, you
know, it could run either
in Google or Amazon.
So as we sort of get more and
more systems in the Cloud,
we want to converge
ways we manage things.
JP ROBINSON: I think
one interesting way
that we've also tried to manage,
like, part of this transition
is that as services in Google
are needing services in Amazon,
we're actually running
Cloud Endpoints in AWS
to expose those services.
So it's actually been
a nice way for us
to get out of the mentality
that everybody's really
defense via firewalls to
actually expose ourselves
to the public securely
using common tools.
DEEP KAPADIA: Yeah.
There's actually
a story to that.
And I don't know-- like, I
know you guys like stories.
So--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We love stories.
MARK MANDEL: We love stories.
Go ahead with the story.
DEEP KAPADIA:
--like, when we first
started looking at Google,
as I said, like, you know,
we've traditionally done
things a certain way.
And we were trying to sort
of replicate our data center
in Amazon.
So like, any app deployed
to Amazon or our data center
should be indistinguishable
from each other, right?
That was sort of the philosophy
we wanted to go with.
So we tried to do
that with Google.
We quickly learned
that, like, you know,
we were basically fighting
what was inevitable.
Like, with Google, like, it
assumed, like, a zero trust
network.
There was no clear notion of
private networking at the time.
Like, now, I know you guys have
EPCs and Peering, and things
like that.
But like we were talking
about a year ago, like,
GCP didn't have that.
So there was no easy
way for applications
to talk to each
other that existed
in different projects,
or applications
that we were building in
GCP to talk to services that
were sitting in our data center,
because our data center was
behind, like, a firewall,
and we couldn't, like, really
open those ports up.
So what we started
doing was, you
know, we found a
novel way around it,
which was using Google
Cloud endpoints.
And it allowed us to
basically stand up something
in our Amazon environment using
the Cloud endpoints service
proxy to actually proxy all
the traffic to our data centers
from Google.
So the teams that were moving
at a faster pace in Google--
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
DEEP KAPADIA: --were able to
continue building in Google
by exposing some of the
underlying services in our data
center and Amazon.
So that was our learning.
Like, you know, like, if teams
want to move at their own pace,
they can continue to
move at their own pace.
And let's not try and fight this
whole, like, private networking
battle in Google
because you know what,
let's just assume
zero trust network.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So what you're saying is
that you are basically
exposing most of your
APIs in the open,
but you're doing so in--
DEEP KAPADIA: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--in a secure way.
So I'm curious about,
how are you doing that?
Are you doing OAuth 2?
What exact authentication
system are you using there?
DEEP KAPADIA: It's mostly--
like, some of the
APIs were retrofitted
to, like, have, like, auth
token in front of them.
Others that could sort of be
modified a little bit more
are using JWP to
secure themselves.
And then, you know,
in other cases,
some APIs already had
auth mechanisms built in,
which allowed us to just
use the proxy as is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And in order
to communicate with each other,
you are using directly
HTTP with JASON, or--
so REST APIs, are you
using any kind of GRPC,
or any other RPC framework?
DEEP KAPADIA: Yes and no.
I mean, yes and yes.
Sorry.
So for the older
APIs, like, they
were already JASONed over REST.
We are definitely
looking into GRPC.
I know some of JP's APIs
are already built with GRPC
as the transport mechanism.
And JP can tell you a
little bit more about that.
But we also recently released
our publishing pipeline,
which is basically the content
pipeline from when a reporter
and editor, like, enter
a story into our CMS,
it has to basically go through
a whole workflow, where
it gets published to a
pipeline and, like, there
are all these consumers
that are waiting
for, like, the new edits
or new updates to a story,
or an entirely new story, or
any new assets to a story.
They're all listening
to this pipeline.
And transport mechanism
for the pipeline is GRPC.
And the pipeline, basically,
is a large message log
sitting on top of KAFKA.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
JP, can you tell us a bit
more about your experience
with the GRPC?
I'd be curious to know.
JP ROBINSON: Sure, sure.
So like I said,
most of my services
are running on App Engine, where
most of our external traffic
is actually coming
in from user facing
apps and things like that.
So most of that mechanism--
most of our authentication
and things like that are just
using our existing New York
Times user authentication.
It gets interesting when we
start going to the service
to service type
of authentication.
When it comes to
App Engine itself,
we actually get to rely on
that one specific header.
It's like the X App ID header.
And we can just
guarantee that that
will sign the incoming request,
and we know it's from our app.
Kubernetes, it starts getting
fun with GRPC, though.
We recently launched
one service where
it is a GRPC service underneath
the hood with Cloud endpoints
on the front, running on GKE.
Since we are also calling
this service from App Engine,
we're actually also
leaning on the fun feature
that Cloud endpoints
does, the HTTP JSON
translation to GRPC for us.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
JP ROBINSON: And that actually
kind of ties back to one
of our open-source tools
called Open API to Proto,
where we actually describe
our API in an OpenAPI spec,
and generate Protobufs that
mimic that OpenAPI spec--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JP ROBINSON: --with
the HTTP annotations.
So we can describe our service
in an OpenAPI spec translated
to Protobuf, handed
to Cloud endpoints,
in that it's exposed in both
of those transport styles quite
seamlessly for us.
It's kind of nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's really cool.
MARK MANDEL: That's very cool.
As much as I'd love to talk to
you both about all this stuff
forever, we are running out
of time just a little bit--
oh, actually, quite a lot.
So before we wrap up,
is there anything else
that you might want to
tell people, or to plug,
or if there's something
particularly amazing
that you've done, or
a lesson that you've
learned that you want to
share that we haven't managed
to touch on yet?
Is there anything
you'd like to add?
JP, we have you right now.
JP ROBINSON: Sure.
For me, honestly, moving all the
games platform to Google Cloud
has been a rather wonderful
experience, honestly.
We just get to worry about
our product and the problems
we should be solving,
and not necessarily
common infrastructure
problems and the like.
It's actually been quite nice.
And with a team of two people,
we are able to do quite a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Deep, yourself.
DEEP KAPADIA: What I've
learned is, I think,
we want to build more
tooling around being
able to help teams move faster.
So I think that's sort
of where we want to be.
Like, we want to
shift our mentality
from being traditional,
like, systems people--
like, you know, people
who manage infrastructure,
to people who actually build
automation around the Google
infrastructure.
So I think that, to us, has
been a very interesting shift
in mentality.
And I think if there are
other organizations who
are trying to make
the shift, I think
that's where, like, you know,
they will find a lot of bang
for their buck,
and like, you know,
in terms of investing in talent.
I think we've made
that investment,
and I think we are reaping
the benefits, at this point.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I
wanted to add one more thing,
which is, for everyone that
is interested in the New York
Times and everything
you're doing tech,
you do have open.nytimes.com--
DEEP KAPADIA: We do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --which is
basically where we're taking,
like, half of our cool
things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
I just wanted to say--
so JP Robinson, you
read a lot in there.
But there's also
other people that
write not only
about Go, but, like,
also CSS and stuff like that.
So I just wanted to
thank all of the authors
in there, because it is
really, really cool content.
JP ROBINSON: Awesome,
thanks for the shout out.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, yeah, thanks to both of
you, Deep, JP, for joining us.
I really appreciate you taking
the time to hang out with us
and chat about what everything
you're doing at New York Times.
DEEP KAPADIA: Thank you so much.
JP ROBINSON: Yeah, our pleasure.
Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thanks, JP and Deep.
We appreciate the insights on
how you guys are using GCP.
So, Mark, let's get to
the question of the week.
How do you secure
Kubernetes' cluster?
What are some best practices to
securing a Kubernetes cluster?
MARK MANDEL: I'm glad
you asked, because I'm
able to reference a wonderful
blog post that has been written
on the GCP blog
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's very helpful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, from
product manager Aaron Small.
Yeah, it's great when other
people do my research for me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: No, it's
actually-- there's a bunch
of different things that you
can do in terms of security
best practices for your
Kubernetes cluster.
I will definitely put a link in
the show notes to the blog post
so you can read it yourself.
There's a few things
in here that I
think are particularly good.
There's a bunch
of stuff in there
about using least privileged
service accounts on your nodes.
So basically, when
you set up the nodes
with your new
Kubernetes cluster,
you can give them permission
to do certain things
within your cluster.
You may or may not
want to do that.
So if there's no
necessary reason for, say,
a particular node to access
Pub/Sub, for example, or Google
Cloud Storage, maybe there's
no reason for them to do that,
then you might want
to turn that off.
If there's no reason for them
to be accessing other Compute
Engine instances, you
can set up firewalls
to do that sort of thing.
Other nice stuff in there,
there is a Kubernetes web UI.
You can actually turn that off.
There's a command line
here to turn off the UI.
The UI has administrative access
to do pretty much anything.
So if somebody gets access to
it, which they shouldn't, you
can turn that off.
That means that then, you can
look down how things happen
inside your Kubernetes cluster.
And it's also worth noting
that the attribute based
access control was disabled
by default in Kubernetes 1.8.
And that gave a lot more
access to Kubernetes.
Now, R-back, which is the
role based access control,
was released as beta
in Kubernetes 1.6,
is now the default in 1.8.
And there's commands in here
if you want to turn that off
for existing-- if you want to
turn off that attribute based
access control.
Anyway, good for R-back.
R-back is the one you want.
That is the one you want.
MELANIE WARRICK: So basically,
you can turn everything off--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--and cap it all,
to keep it from anybody
accessing things
you're not even using.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly, yeah.
So use R-back.
R-back is good.
And also, if you want to
get to the nitty gritty,
you can also do cluster
network policies.
So you can basically do
firewall rules for pods,
defining how they can
talk to the outside world,
or between themselves, as well.
And that's another way you
can also lock things down.
But definitely
read the blog post.
It's well worth your time.
And it will give you some
ideas on how you can get things
locked down and more secure.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
OK, so Mark, are you going
anywhere fun for December?
MARK MANDEL: December
is still going to MIGS.
So I'll be in Montreal
as of next week.
Montreal International
Games Summit.
That's where I'll be.
You'll be at NIPS, or
you're still at NIPS.
What are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: Right,
so this week, I'm at NIPS.
And I am basically
here through the week.
And at the end of
the week, there's
actually an event that
I'm going to be attending,
which I'm looking forward to.
And that's specifically an
event for Black In AI, which
is an organization that
is fostering basically
a community of researchers
that identify, self-identify,
as Black, and/or they're allies.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So it's an event
that's going to be happening at
the Marriott Renaissance Long
Beach Hotel.
For anybody who's in the
area and wants to come,
please come check it out.
MARK MANDEL: And that's
December the 8th,
if I'm reading this right?
MELANIE WARRICK: That is
December 8th on Friday
between 1:00 and 6:00.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we'll
have a link on the blog.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, Melanie.
Well, thank you once
again for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks, Mark.
So I think next
week is the full--
like, we're finally going to
have an interview together.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're actually doing an
interview together next week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
next week is the wrap,
the end of year review, too.
So we bring back Francesc.
And we're going to go through
and talk about kind of,
what have been the popular
episodes for the year, as well
as some personal favorites.
MARK MANDEL: It's
a good episode.
I know how it goes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very
much to all our listeners.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]